okay remember Tariq he was the corn kid  he went viral on social media for his  love of corn he's missing his front  tooth okay so here's the video in case  you don't remember  it tasted good did you think Cory wasn't  real he wasn't sure it was real plus his  heart well I had a Thanksgiving to  seven-year-old internet sensation has  partnered with green giant to promote  corn  you can never have too much cold  [Music]  doesn't stop there he's gonna be on  green Giant's harvest in the valley  float at Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade  oh look at his eyes that's so incredible  he's cute  there you go but he also got his other  front tooth back he did it he's grown a  little bit older but even with missing  the front tooth in the original video he  did a good job on that corn on the  corner that's right yeah that's tough  but there's a will there's a way to find  out it's real you can never have too  much cone that is so cute I love the way  he says that 548 here